es una carrera contrarreloj para los
guardacostas de Estados Unidos y Canadá
que buscan a las cinco personas a bordo
de un submarino desaparecido el 18 de
junio una embarcación sumergible operada
por oceangate expeditions desapareció
frente a la costa sureste de Canadá una
hora y 45 minutos después de comenzar
una inmersión para explorar los restos
del Titanic la guardia costera
estadounidense dijo que un piloto y
cuatro pasajeros van a bordo y que la
embarcación tiene capacidad de
permanecer sumergida durante 96 horas
alrededor de 4 días sin embargo
agregaron que no hay Claridad si todavía
está bajo el agua o si salió a la
superficie y no puede comunicarse
la ubicación de esta búsqueda Es
aproximadamente a 900 millas al este de
cabo coz a una profundidad de 4.000
metros aproximadamente
es un área remota y es un desafío
realizar una búsqueda allí pero estamos
desplegando todos los recursos
disponibles para asegurarnos de poder
localizar la nave y rescatar a las
personas a bordo
los guardacostas han desplegado varios
aviones y barcos para explorar tanto las
profundidades como la superficie
mientras se acercan a los barcos
comerciales en búsqueda de ayuda la
compañía Ocean Gate inició sus misiones
de inmersión profunda en 2017 logró
llegar a los restos del Titanic por
primera vez en 2021 y luego nuevamente
en 2022 la expedición cuesta alrededor
de 250 mil dólares por persona
entre los pasajeros que se cree están a
bordo se encuentra el multimillonario
británico James Hombre de negocios que
publicó en redes sociales sobre la
inmersión en 1912 durante su viaje
inaugural de Inglaterra a Nueva York el
Titanic chocó contra un iceberg y se
hundió matando a más de 1500 personas
los restos descubiertos en 1985 se
separaron en dos piezas principales a
640 kilómetros de la isla de Terranova
en Canadá una historia que ha fascinado
a generaciones desde entonces